[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down the episode 7 trailer for
The Last of Us we're finally getting the
Riley episode and throughout this video
we're going to be going over the game's
similarities and also giving our
thoughts on when we think the episode's
gonna end up full spoilers ahead for
what happens to Riley but but if you've
watched any scene where Ellie is talking
about her friend then you probably
already know anyway I don't want to
waste any more of your time so let's
play the trailer
[Music]
you don't fight your friend's place
she's not here anymore
we follow the rules you
we're the only thing holding this all
together
Riley
I will tell you everything you have to
come with me for a few hours
you trust me right open your eyes
tonight I'm gonna show you the four
wonders of them all
if you come back we could be running
things we're like the future you're a
firefly yes Ellie put it down none of
this [__] was even about me
get ready to run
okay so this entire episode seems like
it's gonna be based heavily on the Left
Behind DLC that was put out after the
game's release this took place in the
timeline right after gel fell off the
horse and we followed Ali she scrounged
for supplies in an abandoned mall during
the winter on the flip side of this we
also got a flashback of her last night
with Riley in which the pair went to an
abandoned Mall which is where they had
an impromptu date it ended in tragedy
with the infected swarm in the area
which is when the pair got bit now on
the flip side of this Ali had to fight
against the infected in the mall and
some Hunters that had been sent out
looking for them I played the recent
remake and was hoping they'd put this in
the game when it happened but
unfortunately you had to select it from
the main menu which kind of sucked
hashtag first world problems anyway I
think we are clearly getting these two
timelines in the episode as we start off
with the shot of Ali going to grab a
doorknob you can catch that she's
wearing a purple coat and this is the
same one that Maria gave to her in
episode 6. so we're definitely getting
the timeline jump and maybe seeing Ellie
searching for supplies as she tries to
effects of gel now it looks like we're
going back to Mucho in the timeline than
when we start with left behind we catch
Ali running circuits and this is likely
for the federal Academy that you train
with back in Boston this location
appeared in the comics and in that we
also had Ellie's Walkman which he
appears to be wearing here a girl grabs
his offer and says that her friend's not
there anymore this is clearly referring
to Riley who ended up leaving the
academy to become a firefly we actually
learned about what happened in the game
with this when Riley is taking her
through the city remember that Firefly
you bet installed his gun
yeah I remember him that's Trevor I saw
him walking down the street so I tailed
his ass
I follow him into this alley and all
these fireflies Ambush me
they took me right to their hideout to
Marlene
were you scared
terrified I thought this time she would
actually shoot me
but instead she just says what took you
so long
she was expecting me
and she just made you a firefly
something like that
that whole almost killing me thing was a
test
she wanted to know I was committed
oh come on now rightly not being there
to protect Ali has made her a bit of an
easy target and even though she's
fighting back she clearly misses her
friend this is definitely foreshadowing
her relationship with Joel and how she
sort of needs someone in her life who
can help by their battles because others
will pick on her she hates the girl and
from here we get taken to a federal
officer's room which is where she gets a
bollocking for not hitting the thumbs up
button and liking the videos her hoodie
looks terrible too but she'd look way
better in Our Last of Us inspired fungi
t-shirt which is available at Zero
edition the Link's in the description
and the officer says they're the only
thing holding us all together I've seen
with Kathleen that's kind of the case
too for as bad as Federer is they at
least have rules and laws in place
whereas the rebels that oust them don't
even saw Kathleen executing people
without trials killing kids and just
being a bad bad dinner lady I don't know
what you worked as she's got dinner lady
Vibes off here no I'm not slagging off
dinner ladies if anything I'm saying
they're too nice they're too bloody nice
anyway
so maybe Kathleen hated kids because she
used to be a dinner
I think the episode's very much going to
be the Clashing of ideologies as Ellie's
in the federal Camp currently whereas
Riley as a firefly it's very much the
story about two people being on opposite
sides of the track that end up coming
together and I would catch Riley
sneaking into Ellie's room which is
pulled directly from the game she woke
up belly by pretending to bite air and
this very much foreshadow their fate in
which they both got bit now Ellie
clearly doesn't take kindly to being
woken up like this and she pulls her
knife out on her and from this they head
out to the city which is what they did
in the game they jump across rooftops
and end up going to the mall in the game
you ended up dropping down into it and
you found a couple of campsites for a
recently deceased hermit called Winston
alien Riley had known him and they ended
up searching through his stuff which is
when they found the pun book you learned
that Riley actually gave Elliot and
Beyond just being filled with great
jokes she loved it because it was the
last thing Riley owned Ali promises to
show her the four wonders of them all
and this included starting up the
Merry-Go-Round this was a big moment in
the game in which the pero ran on it and
rileywood Ali with puns you also see
them holding hands but this quickly
devolves when Ali comes across a pipe
bomb on his shelf it seems like she only
finds out she's a firefly here whereas
Riley told her early on in the DLC after
showing her the Firefly pendant and all
these storms out saying that none of
this was even about her and it's
possible in the show Riley's trying to
recruit her Ali would obviously be
annoyed when she thinks she's getting
closer to Riley only to learn the truth
now she clearly ends up going back as we
see other scenes involving the infected
the surgical shoulder one that's grown
into the wall waking up and these used
to later the game though some Infected
would gone to become clickers there were
many that would just go lie down
somewhere and then they'd grown to the
wall and out from there this is clearly
the case with this one but he's woken up
to go and get the two girls we then see
a location that's pulled directly from
the game and this is the Halloween store
in the DLC it traveled in the mall and
went into his shop lined with masks
which he tried on this included a clown
one which you can see the display of to
the left hey mate I didn't realize you
featured in the episode you clown
we have a laugh at the channel don't we
uh I think it's because we're actually
such a good mates and we can joke about
this kind of stuff you and me there's no
politics involved don't bring up
politics I said I won't listen here
anyway it looks like they're fighting
the infected here which is a nice change
up from the game originally you and
Riley went to a clothes shop for the
final bit which is where you had a water
pistol fight Riley then put on Etta
James I got you babe and you danced
around before the pair kissed originally
the fireflies were shipping Riley off to
another QC but she then promised to stay
in Boston to be with Ellie in fact it
then swarmed the area and cut this love
story short which led to a big chase
scene in the end the pair were bit and
they promised to lose their minds
together which led to Riley's death
looks like it's following the same basic
structure and I'm guessing this is gonna
sort of be used as a dark mirror to the
bill and Frank episode that entry had
two people finding love in the
apocalypse and they managed to live a
long life together this on the other
hand is a relationship being cut short
it's very much going to be a tragic
origin story for Ellie that kind of
explains how she is the first person she
got attached to ended up dying as you
can see why in the present she's so
desperate to hold on a Joel really adds
a lot to the series I think and
hopefully I'll see you back on Sunday
night with our big breakdown of the
episode I keep trying to keep things
less than half an hour mainly for my
editors who every time I upload a 40
minute file I couldn't tell I like sake
but there's so much in these entries
that it's actually difficult to do it
anyway that's your lot and I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the trailer we are
in competition right now giving away the
4K Rocky box set of three subscribers on
the 15th of March and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
repeat the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now say that to
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of episode 6 which will be
linked on screen right now go over all
the Easter eggs loads of stuff in it
lots of ties to part two lots of
theories to definitely head over there
right after this now the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor and see you next time take care
peace